Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
What
was that?
This is my documentary.
Hold on.
Look.
Me.
Why the do you look so flat?
Because I haven't gotten a pillow for it yet.
So he's flat.
right now.
Because I haven't gotten the pillow for him yet.
Is that tea on the left?
It is!
It's my tea!
Yumi!
I'm drinking Gammaicha, as I always do.
It's in my favorite mug even.
Look at the...
Look at my finger.
It's so lumpy.
Lump...
Lumpy finger.
Can I have a sip?
No.
Can you give us a smooch please?
The glove is bigger than you.
These are pretty...
Why is it so lumpy?
Like, you see this?
Look at this!
Wait.
Do I have another pair?
Hold on.
Gloves.
Goodbye.
Lumpy gloves.
Oh, I will move my...
Oh, I think I forgot to tweet.
I will move my keyboard once I am prepared.
There we go.
That's much better.
I don't know how I would do anything.
with those other gloves.
Wow!
Oh, hold on also.
There we go.
Lumpy no more!
Just a little bit.
Just a little bit lumpy.
Lumpy no more!
Nice desk.
Thank you!
Welcome to my streaming desk.
And such.
Hold on, don't look at that.
Yeah.
As you can see, I like cinnamarol.
Small cute.
Maya Oshi has lumpy hands.
No!
Why do you have the extra lumpy gloves?
Well, I didn't buy them with the intent of them.
Oh, I need a tweet.
With the intent of them being lumpy.
Twitter Haunting now
Tweet Oh my gosh, you guys love me Live tweet Yeah, look at
this When I tweet Or no, not when I tweet When I type It
does the thing where like So It turns the color Of what I
type So, look at the T.
Yeah, it's fantastic.
And then, you guys probably can't see.
My escape key.
It's not focusing.
But my escape key is Minto.
My escape key is Minto.
Focus camera.
It's okay.
I'm using a different webcam today, so I'm not quite used to
it.
Three Months of Fun from a Lurker.
Devana, thank you!
It's blurry, but it's cute.
Yeah, I got it from Off-Kai.
Sorry, I don't remember the artist.
I'm so sorry.
She said chew.
Anyway, let's put my keyboard somewhere.
Because I'm not going to be needing it today.
Or at this moment.
Mint's lumps.
Her lovely finger lumps.
Check them out.
I drive these ghosties crazy.
I do it on the daily.
They treat me really nice.
And they buy me lots of ice.
Hold on.
Cheese.
Cheese!
I put on a looping, or not a looping, I put on like a
playlist rather than a one singular BGM, but if it gets
distracting, just let me know.
Cheese!
Hold on, I can give myself bunny ears.
Yes, and my tea.
Oh, shusha.
I remember the one time I sent my new keyboard and one of my
keys came flying off.
That was the day I truly lost control.
Let's get a...
Oh.
Chat summary auto-generated experiment.
Quality may vary.
VTubers are talking about the streamer's cute minto keyboard
and are excited about the possibility of a concert or single
release.
I was earlier on Doki's stream and we announced that we'll
be doing...
She's at... what is it?
Annie Rivo, I think?
And we'll be doing a concert together!
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee,
yippee, yippee, yippee!
and so yay we're doing a concert together she invited me I
was so I was like where really me oh my god so yeah um if
you didn't watch I was on her uh her stream earlier and we
announced that and we did some VR chat shenanigans I felt
really bad though I'm sorry if I felt maybe a little low
energy in it because I um uh I I like I like put on my
headset and immediately I don't tell her don't tell her I
said this but I immediately felt so sick I'm like okay so
and I kind of mentioned it on the on the stream too but like
five minutes beforehand I was I was spending like two hours
trying to get my my VR chat to work um i was i was maybe
even more than two hours i don't even know and it just
wouldn't work at all and i was like freaking out and i
really freaked myself out into like and then once once it
all worked out it like kind of came down but my brain hurt
and so then when i put on and i hadn't eaten so when i put
on the headset i was like oh no i think i've got to be sick
and so i felt really so sorry if i was low energy but i was
really excited and i love doing stuff in vr chat so vr do be
discombobulating by the end i was like oh my god i think i
might pass away again this is my brain thoughts as they're
coming from my head wait
Yeah, we're gonna be doing that together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I couldn't tell you were low energy.
I'm like, I'm like 85%.
Yeah.
Look at this little guy.
Isn't he so cute?
Emory got him for me.
time ago actually she was like it's literally you it's a
ghost in heaven look how cute oh wait it's upside down look
how cute he is got the wings and everything so he sits on my
desk what else do I have on my desk that's exciting oh I
have this which is my Steinsgate calendar that I haven't up
it's a block calendar but I haven't updated it yeah I have
haven't updated it so the numbers are all wrong but I keep
it here and I look at it and what else do I have oh I have
my my bag of yen well I recently it originally it's a blue
oh it's a blue archive bag but I put my yen in it because I
was like oh now I have a coin purse I'll be going back
soonish so my bag of yen it wasn't originally on my desk but
why is it on my desk I have um My Ayami coaster, I don't use
it, I just like to look at it.
And I have, oh, I don't know if I ever showed this before.
Actually, I'm going to take it out of the sleeve real quick.
So that, you can see it maybe better.
Actually, Ayami drew this for me and gave it to me at Anime
Center.
I don't know if I ever showed you guys before.
It's so cute though, right?
Sorry that it's not focusing very well, but it's so cute.
Push, push.
It's so cute, Ayami Sensei.
Look, she even gave me earrings.
I just noticed.
Like a little ghosty earring.
So cute!
Yeah.
um first time we've seen yeah i have lots of stuff on my
desk what else do i have on here i can show you guys well
that's not on my desk i actually have that like kind of
displayed next but okay you know what the background
changing is annoying me i don't want to i don't like it
anymore what one did i just have it on no no no no no i'll
do this one Oh no, I got rid of my...
I got...
No figures on my desk?
No, I keep my figures in a...
in a...
store in...
in glass.
In a... in its own place.
Display case, display case.
I actually Oh, they're not figures though I have a lot of
acrylic stands in here Oh my gosh I have these Hold on, I
was cleaning earlier
I have I have blue eyes White dragon Cinemaroles I got both
of these from Offkaya actually Someone gifted them I think
two different people gifted them to me Which they're so
They're so funny looking.
They're so cute!
Why?
Because I love Blue Eyes White Dragon and I love Cinemurl!
Obviously!
Now I need a third.
I know!
I can become Seto Mintba.
Yeah.
So if anyone has one and wants to give it to me.
But these two can kiss.
Are they still coming out in the U.S.?
Oh, I don't know.
I think they were announced for the U.S.
actually.
But yeah, whoever got me these, thank you.
I have them with me.
Oh, gosh.
This is just becoming like me showing off my stuff.
That's kind of fun, right?
I never get to...
I think this...
Besides...
The Pachinko.
I think this is my first ever hand cam.
Baby Cori, thanks for the gift!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait.
Thank you, thank you.
I think it's my first...
I'm nervous.
How's it going to be?
What?
But today we're building a thing.
Today we're building...
I mean, I have the box right next to me, as you can see, but
I will show you this box as well.
Sakura Densha.
So basically, there's like this...
I guess it's a...
A fad.
It's like a...
It's really popular now.
to get these like bookshelf inserts that are very that are
like little miniature worlds like a book knock yeah my
fayuchi welcome to membership thank you but yeah so we're
going to be making this one the one that i got they had
other ones too um i don't remember what the other ones were
but i really liked the train so i wanted the train Book
diorama Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah And then all the gnomes that
live in my house Can all like They can take the train to
Wait, are those people on there?
Oh my god, there's actual people On the train
That says here Sakura Nodensha She got gnomes There's like
everything in this In this Made cafe.
But yeah, so I already unboxed it.
Here's our instructions, everybody.
With Sakura fluttering in the sky.
Whisper your name over and over.
Wait, what?
I just read that for the first time just now.
Minto, Minto, what?
Hmm?
Huh?
Avi!
Why?
Why so many gifted?
It makes my wrist look sick.
Why?
Thank you.
Thank you, thanks for the power, crypto.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Or the gnomes taller?
No, they're this big.
Actually, I don't know how big this thing is going to end up
being.
Maybe like...
Do you think maybe this about this high?
About yay high?
About yei-hoi.
Murphy, thanks for the vibe!
Ah, baby!
Why?
All must become wisp.
Thank you for the favor, baby.
No, I'm just kidding.
Chee-ching.
David, thank you for the vibe.
Good time.
Thank you.
Should be as tall as a book.
I have a book.
Hold on.
Um.
What do you think?
Like this one?
Oh, they're basically the same height.
This is the Metal Gear Solid 4.
That's why it says Saraba Snake.
Goodbye Snake.
Farewell Snake.
And then this one's Metal Gear Solid 2, but it's in English.
This one Nihongo.
But I also own the English version of this too.
Oh my gosh.
Eilon!
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you!
And Woda!
Woda the hedgehog.
Thank you for the 5 gift.
Thank you so much!
Did I miss it?
Miss everybody.
C2!
Thanks for the 5!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there's so many!
Jensen's thank you for the 50!
You guys, I can't just be Scarlet.
Thank you for the 5.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Uh, uh.
Yudian!
Thank you for the 5.
Oh my gosh, T-Coff!
Thank you for the five!
Thank you, thank you!
I think I got all of them.
You missed a flood.
What the hell?
Run it!
Thank you for the 20, thank you!
Okay.
So this is our instruction manual today.
Like so.
Oh.
Oshama!
Thank you for the...
Thank you!
Aniribo is local!
Let's go!
See you there then.
They wanted to see if I could do like a meet and greet and
even two, but I was like, I have another convention that
same weekend, unfortunately.
So the timing...
The timing... Maybe one day I'll be invited as an actual
guest, so...
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Hold
on, I'm gonna move my tea over here.
Oh my gosh, wait, hold on.
Oh my gosh, wait, hold on, hold on.
Wait, there's too many, wait, hold on.
Oh my god, oh bl-bl-bl-bl-bl- oh.
Mr. Alpeasy, thank you.
Thank you for the 50 and- and Garlobal, thank you for the
50.
Birthday!
Xybo, thank you for the 10!
Got the same book nook for another wisp about a year ago.
No way, really!
Bozo, thank you for the 5!
Oh my gosh.
You guys, tier 3!
Tire?
Three!
Thank you for the 10!
Tiz himself, thank you for the 10!
Oh my gosh, you guys!
Chat is now all green.
Oh my gosh!
It doesn't stop!
Please!
Please.
Oh, ha!
I'm trying to look for... hold on.
I'm trying to look for my remote for my fan.
I'm just gonna turn it on right here.
I don't know where I put it.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I found it.
My little remote.
Oh my gosh, you guys, I can't even keep up.
I can't even, YouTube is not even letting me scroll through.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Wait, where did I even leave off at?
I don't even know.
Oh my gosh, there's too many.
Nixie, thank you for the 50.
Gubble, thank you for the 10.
Stupid Shark.
Thank you for the 20.
Shirokuma, thank you for the 20.
Star Creator, thank you for the 20.
Tri-Princess, thank you for the 5.
Belfast Art, thank you for the gifted.
Thank you for the gifted.
Kmart, thank you for the 5.
Oh my gosh, I'm already behind.
Albin, thank you for the 5.
English and Fix, thank you for the 5.
Uh, uh, C2, thank you for the 10!
Bid my soul, thank you for the 10!
Wrong for Robin, thank you for the 5!
Yeah, thank you for the 20!
Oh, Emory!
Emory, look, I showed them earlier.
I was like, this is on my desk.
This is on my desk.
Hi Emery!
I keep it, I keep it on my desk.
Very bubbly, thank you for the gifted.
I'm so happy he's haunting your desk.
And she goes, thanks for the turn!
Footpole, thank you for the turn!
No, thank you, thank you!
Thanks for becoming a member!
Thank you!
Academy, thank you for the vibe!
Oh, I think I've got up.
Nice.
Okay.
So, oh, I think I forgot scissors.
Uh-oh.
Because I have all this.
Oh, oh, it's all in plastic.
Um, one second.
I think I have to go get scissors for it.
Look at all these pieces.
Oh, you can see my computer screen.
Let's see, take out some of the stuff.
There's a batteries.
I don't know what this is, glue maybe, glue.
I need scissors, 61.
You guys ever got scissors?
Actually, I think I need to go get some scissors.
I'll be right back.
I'm back, baby.
I'm back.
Okay, stop, stop, I was gone for two seconds.
Empty gloves, she's a ghost.
I know, I know.
That's what I'm saying.
Scissors.
And let me crack this bad boy open.
I'm kind of nervous about making this.
Let's do it carefully, though.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, gosh.
Why?
Why do I have to wear gloves?
No.
That's so that you guys can see me, you know?
It's my ghostliness.
But it's so hard to open anything.
I actually had no intention of doing this on stream.
I bought it for myself.
But I just kind of never did it.
I was like, I never have time to do it.
But maybe I'll just make it on stream is what I said.
Just do it on stream.
Oh my god.
Are you guys?
I'm like, the hole is right here.
The opening is right there.
I just made it.
Come on.
Peel.
We're doing it live, baby.
There we go.
Okay.
Plastic on the floor.
It's okay.
I'm a maid.
I clean it up later.
Plastic.
Whoa.
Pl- Can you guys hear it?
Plastic.
That's not possible.
What is this?
Actually, what is this?
Ooh, oh, huh.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I can't get the rest off.
It smells like, smells like wood.
Oh my God, I'm trying not to break stuff, but, Give me
something to break about your heckin' plastic.
All right, we got, oh, this is a sandpaper to on the stuff.
This is, oh, this is reflective.
Oh, actually, no, it's not so bad.
It's a thing.
I thought it was a mirror for a second.
I had a, I had a little jump scare there.
We have some Sakura something somethings.
Hmm.
I've always wanted to do one of these.
I'm gonna go buy one.
Let's go!
Here's some more thingies.
This reminds me of when I was putting together my...
I have a wooden revolver.
Wow!
Look at all the details and stuff!
Wait, this is just... this is thin actually.
Oh!
Wait, I think something just fell out.
Uh oh.
That part just popped out of that hole.
Oh no, it's too thin.
Uh oh.
Okay.
Um.
We're all ready.
Uh.
I'll just put it right back in there.
Oh, shoot.
Um, just...
What if I put it in like this?
Nice.
Perfect.
Perfection.
Look, there's the people!
That's it.
That's...
Can you see it?
Those are the people.
The people.
Uh-huh.
There's a cat!
Look how cute he is!
Book.
Oh, stories and books.
Stories in books.
Okay.
What do we name him?
We'll name him once we get there.
I think this is the outside of the book, right?
We have some wood.
Oh, this smells.
That's the wood scent.
And, oh my gosh, there's so many pieces.
I don't think we're going to finish this today.
Stories and books and more.
And then all of these.
Sniffer.
No, this one doesn't...
The gloves are gonna be...
Amazing with the glue?
No, the glue is...
A pen.
It's a pen.
Rest in glitch days.
Thank you for the five!
Thank you!
Why?
It'll be fine.
Until the glue... the gloves...
F with the glue?
Oh, no, no, no.
We'll be fine.
Okay, let me put all of this now.
I moved my tea over there, but I'm actually going to move it
over here.
I also have these.
I don't know if I'll need them.
I have some Gundam nips.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Let's read the instructions and see what we need first let's
go stories and stories and stories and stories oh
we're fine my strength has no no bounds okay this thing
ruined soiled it soiled it
and then this is a battery pack because it's actually has
lights so that's very cool I put that over there I don't
know what these are I think this oh this is looks like a
railroad and then parts and glue soiled it alrighty let's
open our magical book our IKEA instructions that's the fence
oh okay oh equipped with two controllable lights hidden
battery colorful world and river reflection oh my gosh it's
gonna look so good touch there's a touch light how many
pages um 34 30 33 33 page oh look they have okay sakura den
shen den shah sunshine town magic house and time travel wait
time travel has like a really cool train but I think I like
Sakura Den Shamos sunshine town is pretty cool too magic
house looks like you can't see enough of it looks like it
the border blocks too much of it huh but time travel looks
really awesome a sunshine town does too I like the colors in
Magic House.
Wait.
Oh, I like the window!
Oh, it looks really nice, actually.
I'm a sucker for trains.
Me too!
Oh!
I'm already feeling the pressure here.
Please read Q&A in the previous page before...
Here's where my favorite goes made.
warm thank you thank you thank you where's the cue oh what
if there are burrs what's a burr
what's a burr
on the edges of parts
burr a sliver a fuzzy thing a wood knot oh in order to
ensure your safety and and its accuracy please remove the
parts first then use the included sandpaper to polish the
edge burns burrs of the parts okay so if there's any burrs
we sand those guys out how to deal with loose parts after
repeated disassembly apply some glue on joints to fix the
parts what need to be considered when assembling the pet and
mirror remove the films of the pet and mirror before
assembling Then apply some glue on them and press 5 to 10
seconds.
There is mirrors.
Uh-oh.
Burr is a piece sticking out.
Thank you!
The 20th.
Thank you so much.
I really, really appreciate it.
What need to be considered when connecting the battery box
with the light?
Twist the same color.
I'm becoming an electrician?
Twist the same color wires together.
If you connect red with black it will short out after
powering on the light cannot work properly okay same color
same color same colors oh my gosh what if the light cannot
work after connecting the battery box with the lights first
check if the wire connection is wrong correct same color
wires together check if they have loaded the batteries
properly and if the switch is turned on turn off the battery
box switch then tear off the insulation tape check the
copper wire are broken and reconnect.
I'm gonna start a fire with this.
I think I'm gonna start a fire.
Oh god.
How to use the touch light.
After assembly, you can touch the switch on the front board
lightly and all light beads will be on.
Cool.
Okay, I read the Q&A.
Why do you send me things when your name is like that?
Please.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Please mint phantom.
I can't read the rest.
My reading comprehension is so...
They're a real fan.
Is that what we're calling it now?
Alright.
Apply a dab of glue.
Okay, D2C3.
D2...
Oh gosh, I have to go through all of these to find...
What?
Oh my gosh, I have to go through all of this to find D2.
Uh...
Okay, guys.
Time to find D2.
Any Ds in here?
Oh, wait.
No.
These are all numbers, I think.
These are all numbers.
D2.
Oh my gosh, everything's coming apart.
This is a mess.
Nathan, thank you for the five, Captain.
Thank you.
Where are these?
Where are D?
Where is D?
D?
Oh, I found A.
You guys, this is A.
A, A.
This is all A.
A 1 to A 23.
25.
This part is A.
A.
And it was C3.
There's some C's on here.
C3 is this one.
It doesn't look like the picture though.
So which way is this one?
Is C3 facing?
Oh!
It broke.
but it's not even the same shape let's continue onward there
might be another c3 right yeah where is d this this is f one
job Shut up!
There's probably another C3.
This is G.
We are going through the literal alphabet, but we can't find
D.
This, oh, this has to be it.
D!
D2.
Oh, it's tiny.
Oh!
I feel like a poltergeist right now.
D2.
Okay, remember this one is D8.
This is D8.
Stick those back in there.
These are all D2s.
Do I do it with every single one of them?
Oh yeah, I do.
I think.
Wait, A times 2.
B times 2.
Just gonna take all of them.
There we go.
This is like the most...
This is like the worst setup ever to be assembling this.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot.
Wait, where was...
Oh, shoot.
I forgot C.
Hold on.
I gotta bring back the C3.
PO.
C3 people!
So I just take...
Huh?
I'm confused.
It barely starts it already struggling.
No!
C3 to D2.
And then which, but which way is it facing?
Okay, hold on.
Get out.
Get out of there.
I'm gonna sand this guy.
This guy has, he's got some burrs on him.
It took me 12 hours, but I built a whole moving wooden
working ovary.
Solar system model out of a kit.
If I may offer some advice, spite helps.
Ha, yeah!
I'm the greatest at being spiteful.
I'm a ghost after all.
It's an ovary, right?
I didn't say ovary.
You guys put that in my mouth.
Orary.
Or...
It's a solar orb.
Oh, wait.
Each side is the same color.
So we just kind of...
Look!
Okay, I've got to glue it.
Hold on, I'm also gonna...
Oh, wait.
It is that side.
Oh, it doesn't matter which side, I guess.
I hope.
Actually, it should matter.
Because...
Okay, I'm looking at the little, the little, there's a
little, this, this little bugger right there, that guy's
sticking out.
That needs to be on the, this, like, I'm, I'm, I'm gaming,
okay?
I'm gaming, I know what I'm doing.
Okay, okay,
okay.
I have a backlog of model kits to build, but was able to
finish a cool big O kit.
Where's my glue?
Here it is.
Glue?
I think I hear birds.
Okay.
Wow, where should I put the glue on?
A dab, apply a dab of glue on shaded areas.
Oh, the, oh, the rim, the rim, the rim.
Ooh, okay.
Wait, does this need to be cut?
Oh, wait, there's a seal in there.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
It comes undone.
Wait, how do I get the seal?
How do I get the seal out?
Did they give me a poker?
I hardly even know where...
Wait, where do I get the seal?
They didn't give me a poker!
How am I supposed to get the seal out?
Needle or a pin?
I have my Sensei pin, but I don't think it's long enough.
I have my Blue Archive Sensei pin.
My Shale pin.
Toothpick?
I don't have that either.
Thumbtack.
Oh, wait.
Maybe if I go in from the inside with it.
Hold on.
I've got to take off my gloves for this.
This made me want to build my MGS Rex model kit.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna try.
I think it'll work.
Go, Sensei!
I think it's working.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I got it.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Yes, Sensei.
Sensei, Sensei.
Yes.
All right, nice.
Building along with you, Minto, but mine's a Lego bonsai
tree set.
Ooh.
Are you guys ready to craft with Minto?
together you're an indie VTuber home I wear them because I'm
a ghost not cuz I'm an indie VTuber otherwise you wouldn't
be able to see my hands because I'm a ghost okay what sucks
is for you guys to see and for me to do this it's kind of
far away so um uh um uh so um i have i can't see very well
am i put am i doing it well am i putting it on nice i hope
so god my hands are kind of shaky oh i'm getting glue on my
gloves just like you guys
Oh gosh, I'm getting it.
You guys, I'm getting it in other places.
Okay.
There we go.
Perfect.
Oh, yeah.
Just mix it in.
That, oh.
Oh, it's on the sides.
Oh, it's leaking.
It's leaking.
it's leaking.
It's okay.
Just mix it in.
Don't see the glue on the in the... Don't look at the...
Uh-oh.
I hope that dry is clear.
Actually, hold on.
Sensei.
Sensei can scrape it out.
I love Sensei pin.
Yeah.
And just wipe it on my gloves I'll put them in the wash
later I'm a maid it's fine it just looks like it's like
leaking a little like they have a a problem you know like
some sort of some sort of problem okay do I do that for all
of them oh assemble two sets of parts all right we got to do
that again for another set okay
Sensei is leaking?
No, I think, uh...
Maybe, actually.
Okay.
Wait.
I think...
Yes!
Wait, huh?
I'm confused.
I put it on the back here.
Hold on.
Okay, I'm confused.
So, remember how I said, like, oh...
The notch is on the left side here.
Right there.
So I put it on the left side is here as well.
But then here.
It's on.
The left side.
But it's showing.
Put the glue on the shaded area.
Huh?
But then here.
Did I mess up?
No, it's the same thing.
Wait, huh?
Is it two different ones?
Maybe it's the same thing, but...
Oh, I think I assembled two of each!
I assembled two of this one, and then I assembled two of
this way.
We're okay!
We're okay, so I need to make another one where the notch is
on the right and then I make two where the notch is on the
left because it says here assemble two of sets of parts and
then here it says assemble two of yeah see who I was nervous
for a second okay so this guy will be facing this way these
guys will be facing that way yeah okay well where's my C
there we go
C3.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh, it fell in between my pants.
Okay, there we go.
C3.
C3, C3, C3, C3, C3.
She's gaming.
So yeah.
Ghostwear pants?
Yeah.
My ghost pants?
My, uh...
Ecto pantsums?
Duh.
Ghost, IRL Ghost Gaming.
Oh yeah, you're pink!
Thank you!
Asto!
I got another gifted membership.
I can't buy myself.
Thanks, guys, and minto.
Ah!
Congratulations!
the the ghost the the membu lottery
matara always told us you're a maid uniform i am but
sometimes i have ectopants on duh it's like normal okay i
can hear a good storm approaching in the first super chat
saying a soul and won't be the last.
It just arrived.
What's that one?
Have you guys ever seen those
those like they seem like auditions for something but they
make no sense.
It's just like, honey you got a storm coming and then they
do something like with their hand.
They're like
honey, you got a big door I'm coming yeah I don't need
friends they just disappoint me okay so this is the one we
did and we'll do this one so we glue this part okay
why I didn't even I barely even why okay okay okay we can
fix this we can fix this oh no no no no I touched it!
Dassey!
Sansدي!
Wait, where did I put?
Uh oh.
Where did I put Sensei?
Wait, this is bad because I didn't put the cap on so it's
spiky right now.
I'm not gonna sit on it.
I'm not gonna sit- I'm not gonna get a...
I'm not gonna get a spike up my butt!
Am I...
Oh gosh!
Wait.
Oh, I found it!
I found it.
Okay.
I gotta get it from the corners.
Um, which side am I working on?
I think this side.
Okay, we can do this now.
See?
This is how much pressure I put on before.
And it exploded on me.
Take the glue.
Smear it.
the glue just eat it up eat up the glue eat up the glue eat
up the glue okay now we get sensei back
which he dropped to the floor trying to pick up with my toes
does anyone else do that they pick up stuff on the floor
with their toes do not eat the glue oh my gosh that was one
of my least favorite episodes of the power of girls when i
was a kid there was an episode where this guy ate glue i
think he had a crush on buttercup but he just like ate the
glue and it made me feel so sick every time oh no it has
hair on it has cat hair on it okay we're good so now we get
the corners i remember that episode i think they both ended
up eating glue That's my Oshi.
She eats glue.
And your Oshi would eat glue too.
The horrible part about this is I actually want it to look
nice.
So...
I want this to look nice because I'm going to put it on my
shelf.
I don't want it to be gross and glue.
Wait, how did I do the wrong side?
How did they end up facing different directions?
okay this goes on this side then
oh my god okay so we're gluing this side oh hold on i gotta
sand it down a little bit you guys this is gonna be good
when i built my revolver um i accidentally got to like the
very almost to the very end and realized it was all back and
had to take it apart and redo it.
So you know, it happens.
Easy squeeze.
Easy squeeze, easy squeeze.
Okay, there we go.
Easy squeeze.
Easy squeeze, easy squeeze.
I mean, but truly, who's...
You know what these...
Only the pictures make these look good, right?
else's always look like, you know, doo-doo garbage.
So, you know, it'll be character.
Mine might be just a little bit, like, you know, um, a
little something.
I don't know.
It's only, it's only ever the model pictures that make these
look good.
You know, everybody else's also look, look bad too, I think,
probably.
Probably.
Not probably.
Definitely.
That's why you buy two.
It'll be unique.
It's gonna look like a labyrinth.
What are you talking about?
The McDonald's advertising.
Look!
Two of the same!
Oh,
my fingers smell like glue.
And now this one.
We're on step two, you guys.
We're almost at step three.
How many steps are there?
There were 34 pages and...
Or 33 pages.
Oh, and there's only 30...
Only 31 steps!
We are so good.
Oh, we got this.
We're already on step two.
Almost three.
Copium supplies have run dry globally.
No, that's why I don't allow copium in my chat.
Because there is no copium here.
There's no copium in Basingse.
Okay.
Everything I speak is real.
Everything that I say happens.
Happens.
I say Minto's gonna do it.
I do it.
No copium.
it bust and say yes nice and easy I just got to get around
my fingers there we go beautiful don't mind the glue covered
fingers okay everybody it's probably I hope it's a non-toxic
glue probably is though you think get to wipe the glue off
the sides um and get sensei in never gonna be able to use
this this uh pin ever again
two facing this side two facing this side okay next we need
b2 b3 b18 what was B which one was B I have a I have C see
see step two completed you guys we're doing it we're doing
it we're doing it I have G I have F I have
I...
B2, B18, bingo!
3.
This is the really woody one.
It's a really good one.
I have D.
Did I ever...
I have... I think this must be B.
E?
Where's B?
I have H?
A?
D?
Uh.
Wait, is this actually B?
But it...
Oh, it's B?
I thought it was 3.
Wait.
Look at this.
Okay, you can't see it at all.
But none of the...
Okay, so on all the bees, on every single one of them, on
every single one of them, the line isn't filled in.
So it looks like...
Gosh, this is the one moment I wish it would focus forever.
It looks like three!
I'm gonna take a picture of this right now with my phone.
I'm taking a picture.
So that you guys believe me.
Oh, and the camera looks like a bee.
No, it all...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Right here, right here.
Okay, I took a picture.
I'll post it later.
What did I need?
It looks like...
It's the lighting.
That's why.
Where did my other thing go?
Ah!
He fell.
Alright.
We're good.
I need a B2.
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna use my camera.
I can't tell.
I'm using my camera.
Oh.
Oh, gosh, hold on.
B12?
Is that B1C or B10?
B32?
Oh, wait, B132?
I can't tell.
I seriously can't tell.
Oh, wait, B1, B2.
I need B2.
Okay, I found B2.
I found it I'm fighting I'm fighting for my afterlife over
here And then I need B3 Okay I have both of those And now I
need B18 Okay hold on Let's start with getting Let's start
with getting Okay so this here Is B2 and this one's B3 Okay
Oh Nice B2 Some of it came off.
Tool B2.
Or not tool B2.
Okay, and now B18?
This one.
Ooh, this one.
This one right here.
It's kind of tricky because it's like it's, I don't want to
break it.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
Oh gosh, I'm scared of breaking it.
I'm scared of breaking it.
I'm in self of it.
These three seed...
I'm scared of breaking it.
The iPad jumps in a room?
You're right!
That's so funny.
Okay, okay, oh, oh.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
I'm scared.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Oh, okay.
Why do they have the tiniest piece?
Or the thinnest piece in the middle?
Oh, why they have the thinnest piece in the middle.
It's so hard to push it out.
Tiny knife time.
I think my nips are too thick.
Oh, I can't believe I broke it.
I would never survive in squid game.
No!
How to get it out?
You dink that.
If I broke it, it would come out.
It would be nice to me.
No!
I'm making it worse!
I got it out.
Let me try the glue.
No!
It's top three!
I do have super glue if I need it, though.
I have to go get it, though.
Okay, I'm going to do this off camera.
So I can be precise.
I will do it off camera.
Okay, hold on.
It goes like...
Yeah.
We can fix it.
I will put you back together.
Step 3 or step 3.
Stop!
I don't think the glue is strong enough, but we'll see.
We'll see.
28 steps to go.
Yep.
I feel like I should go get the super glue.
But we'll try this real quick.
We could save it.
Maybe.
Okay.
Okay, I'm holding it.
Hold.
No, no, no.
It came apart.
Hold.
Hold!
I'm holding it!
How long should I hold it for?
It's a little wobbly.
Oh gosh, it's a lot of wobbly.
But it's staying together.
I'm gonna hold it for some more.
Hold!
10 minutes!
What will we do for 10 minutes?
Let it set for a while.
Okay.
Look, though, it's together!
I'll let it sit by itself.
And think about what it's done wrong.
Oh, but I need to put...
Uh-oh.
I need to put these pieces inside the holes.
These diagrams suck.
Okay.
Let's put this over here.
B14.
Oh, no one needs to go in here.
Oh, wait.
This is the sign, I think.
You can barely read it here, though.
Like...
Look at this.
If you think you can't read anything, you can kind of see
the indents of like the letters and stuff, but that's
supposed to say something.
I could only read it with my camera.
Is that even 14?
Yeah, that's B14.
That's the sign.
What it did wrong was falling into your hand.
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
This is...
This, this, this, this, this...
This...
You...
This is wrong slanderous!
I love catching mint live because it means it's way past my
bedtime.
Asia.
But yeah, you can barely read it at all.
Maybe I'll put... I can't...
Oh, mi ta!
Mi ta...
Mi ta?
Mi...
Mi-tala?
I can't read the rest.
Mi-tala is something that I can't read it.
Mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi-mi.
I'm scared though, look at this part!
I'm gonna break- I'm gonna break that off.
Right there?
That?
I'm gonna break that off, I think.
Mi-tara?
No.
No way.
I'm scared of these parts eventually when I have to get to
this too.
Maybe I will use my nips.
Okay.
How do I use them?
Push!
No.
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
No exacto knife?
No, I don't have an exacto knife.
You mean Snips, not Nips?
No, they're called Nips.
I'll have the box around here somewhere.
Oh!
They're called...
They're called an entry nipper.
So I just call them my Nips.
They're for Gundam.
she's not lying why would I lie
it's just easier to say nips isn't it gunplay nips yeah what
are you guys thinking of get your heads out of the gutter we
gotta get this off it'll take the 20 minutes to get it off
that uh That'll take for this to dry.
Look, it's a little crooked it feels.
It's a little...
It's okay, character.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
We did it and we have some birds.
We have got some birds to take care of.
Nice.
A few bows, a few bows.
Gundam naming convention strikes again.
I think it sounds normal.
Yeah!
Oh, uh-oh.
My gloves are starting to get really sticky.
Look.
You can see I'm sticking together.
Maybe if you guys give me enough energy, I can take them
off.
I don't know yet though.
My nails are really bad looking.
So I'd be embarrassed, yeah.
Okay, I don't actually understand this part anyway.
Okay, let's put these guys here.
You?
Does this feel as flimsy as before?
Energy.
Not now, not now.
Oh!
actually pretty okay.
It's actually pretty okay, I think.
Yeah, it's actually, it's not so flimsy anymore.
Nice.
Yippee!
Jason, welcome to membership, thank you!
Thank you!
Ah!
Go them up.
Energy!
Beam!
Thank you.
Okay, so I take B2 and B3.
It's the...
Oh, shoot.
Which one was B2 and which one was B3?
Oh, B3 is this one.
This one's B3.
And I'm going to use my nips to cut this right here.
Nice.
B2 and B3 go they kiss I think oh I'm gonna use them to cut
here there we go okay they kiss they kiss the white side on
the white side or they connect I think they just kiss
actually I'm not quite sure I'm not sure of the oh yeah I
think they kiss they kiss like this and then this part goes
into these holes into these two different holes
but facing down like that i think huh no face this face it
huh kiss kiss for love Snippers you have are for plastic.
Yeah, I know.
And you're really, really a modeling knife for this sort of
stuff.
No, I don't.
Otherwise they would have provided one.
I'm good.
They kiss.
But what's that?
Hold on.
I need to look at this more closely.
Huh?
Okay.
This makes no sense.
What?
How's it supposed to look?
How?
How do you go?
Okay, wait.
How do you go from sticking it into the hole?
Like, see how it's...
Okay, it shows that there's...
kissing and then you stick it into the hole and then they're
sideways they're like making a little birdhouse shape how
does that make any sense huh did i get raided thank you for
the raid sorry i'm so confused they kiss go to the hole and
then to become sideways i guess i'm just gonna make them
suck.
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
They make this.
This is, I get it.
I get it.
I'm gonna do it with my hands, though.
I'm gonna do it with my hands.
I think it'll be easier.
She got the hole.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I get it.
No, I don't think.
I know.
I know I got it.
I got this.
Like that.
And then like this.
And then as they kiss.
Right?
Yeah.
Then they kiss.
Then there's two holes and then the third hole.
Oh, I'm breaking it.
I'm breaking it.
It's gonna snap under my fingers.
I'm gaming?
Yeah, there's a third hole.
Okay, we're gonna do it like this.
Okay, okay.
I got this, you guys.
I believe.
Do you guys believe?
Try making the same model and failed.
I wish you better luck than me.
No, Pop!
No, no, don't say that!
Don't say that, don't say that, don't say that, don't say
that.
say that.
This is my first ever thing that I've ever made.
This is my first one that I've ever made, though.
This is like the...
Then they converge.
I wish I could show you what I'm doing.
The third hole.
Yeah!
I got it.
I got the third hole.
Take your time and you'll be fine.
Now, I'm kind of confused because...
Wait.
No.
Because it doesn't look very even.
Maybe it's supposed to look like that.
Look, it kind of looks like...
Not straight.
But the holes are like that.
They're like uneven, so...
I guess this is uneven too Let me fix this guy
This was the third hole Right there Why does it look like
that?
I don't know I don't know And then we put the sign in here
Like so
And it becomes like a little thing
Ah!
Oh my gosh My glove is stuck on the thing and it just...
Oh god, oh god, okay.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
I'm gonna put it in like this.
I'm gonna put it in.
Nice and gentle, nice and gentle, nice and gentle, nice and
gentle.
Gentle, gentle, gentle.
Maybe it's a perspective thing.
Oh, maybe.
Okay, that's...
Okay, hold on.
Oh, it didn't fit!
Is it working?
I don't think so!
Might be so that it looks better once it's all together.
Okay.
You're right, you're right, you're right.
Easy, easy, easy, easy.
Easy, easy, easy, no.
Easy, oh!
I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared!
Okay, I hope
it's not because I broke it early.
I'm like really trying Did you see that Did you see that
squeeze?
Maybe that's good enough
There we go Yippee!
We have like a little sign And it's so cute!
We have a little sign See?
Yay!
We did step...
4...
1!
Wouldn't this be step...
Why is all of this step 4?
Wait a second.
Oh my gosh.
All of this is step 4!
This is step 5!
This is step 4!
Step 4 is 2 pages!
Okay, we need A24.
Wait a second.
A24.
We need A25.
A18.
What one was A?
What is...
Oh, I found A.
A!
See, these ones are so legible, so easy to read.
Even you can read them with my bad camera.
Okay.
24.
18 Got it I want to be a gnome Maybe you too can in another
life be a gnome
There we go And sand it down just a little bit
Draw the rest of the owl
What?
4 is the best number after all so it goes on forever true I
can't argue what's in
there and then we also oh thank you oh I think all the the
donos are backed up so many gifted she won't notice this
dono saying Minto Q I saw it I saw it I saw it I saw it.
Rishaw.
Yeah.
Okay.
There we go.
Roll.
Roll life.
Life, the power.
All right.
And then A24 and A25.
Which are these two?
Okay.
I have to remember which.
24 is the dotted one.
Everybody.
24 is all spot.
Oh, oh, nice.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Oh, it says 24 on it.
Just kidding.
Okay.
It says 24 on it.
So how do we do this with the with these little lines.
See them?
edge they go like so yes oh never mind i had it though i had
it i had it i had it i had it
yeah i'm winning i'm winning i'm winning i think one and the
other one like so so that 24 is on the inside what is this
thing i'm creating anyway is it like a ac maybe
two this one was so easy oh it's stuck on my
uh i got it
very good
it's all safe in the palm of my hand
Do A22.
And that's going to go on the bottom here.
A22.
This one.
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
I have to make sure I get it, but not A23.
Do I need A23?
No.
Oh, I'll need A23 in a bit, actually.
So we can get them both.
On the next page.
Take them out.
together the twins david and elai i shall name you why is
this piece so thin sir jet thanks for three months thank you
on lunch what am i what are we building we're building a
sakura densha sakura densha sakura densha did i just split
it um i might have just a little bit but it's fine no one
notice the parts terrible george george will come later well
how's it go first mommy then daddy then baby in the carriage
how does it go how's that part go okay this is this is 23
everybody 23 right there first mommy in the first comes love
then comes marriage then comes baby in the baby carriage
then comes george in the george carriage okay it's got to be
the white side facing up is what it's saying and it goes
like this okay
I guess Hmm Yeah solidus is the baby Baby brother Why would
the A22 What the white side be up though Like why would it
be on the inside Why not Why not the part that actually says
A22 On the inside
Curious Actually
Maybe it is on the inside.
I'm looking at the holes.
Okay, that would make more sense, right?
I'm looking at the holes in the diagram.
Yes, all it is is the baby brother, even though he became
president and looks the oldest.
This is the baby.
Oh.
He's just a baby.
First comes big boss, then comes big mama.
Am I doing this wrong?
Come on.
Fit in.
Why are these holes so tight?
Oh, I think it's because it's not able to go in because of
the...
It's being blocked by...
Oh, I am doing it wrong.
This side needs...
This side, this little notch, right there, needs to be
facing outward.
So I was doing it wrong.
Okay.
I guess the A22 does have to be on the outside.
Facing outward.
Because my hands are tiny, I don't think that has anything
to do with it.
Okay.
Oh, see that fifth...
Ouch!
That fits so much easier!
That fits so much more easily.
Okay.
Okay, look at that!
We got a little... thing!
Yay!
Now we do A16, which is this bad boy, and we...
Um...
Stick it in.
We glue it in there, actually.
Minto has baby hands.
You have baby brain.
Where did this come from?
Where did that little dingle hopper come from?
Yeah!
Brutal.
Don't come in the kitchen unless you're ready to get burned.
And now we stick this in here.
Look at that!
But what we're going to do is we're going to glue it.
Oh my gosh, it's so cute!
We got to glue it, though.
We got to glue it.
We glue all of the back.
Or all of this part.
No, all of this part.
Yeah.
We glue all of that.
Where's my glue?
Oh, here.
just just glue it fib thanks for three of mine thank you all
right glue glue glue glue glue glue we can't mess this part
up you guys we can't we can't mess this part up you just put
it in there there's no way we can mess it up you just stick
it on and it's easy easy peasy there's no way we can mess
this up there's no there's no way we can screw it up There's
no way we can screw it up.
It came with the glue?
Yeah, isn't it nice?
There we go.
The blue glue looks delicious.
It's actually white.
It's not blue at all.
I can see why it looks blue.
Little AC unit!
It's so cute!
Oh, there's a little bit of glue.
Will you sense it?
Get it off?
My little tiny sensei.
Nice.
Look how cute that is.
Now we do 823, which is this piece.
And we glue it on, or no, we snap it in on top.
Um.
I guess it doesn't matter which way it goes.
Hopefully.
This is the nicer side.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please.
I hope.
Actually, I don't know.
I hope not.
I can't tell.
No.
I think either side works, right?
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
I got it in.
One side in.
Yay!
Oh, my God!
It's a box!
Oh, my gosh.
This is so exciting.
Yeah!
Do a lot of these pieces need to be glued?
I don't think so.
It'll tell you when to glue stuff.
Oh, wait.
This one has spare parts.
Wait, why didn't B18 have spare parts?
But these A11 and A9 have spare parts.
Why does it B18 have a spare part?
Oh, these ones are really...
Oh gosh.
This is what we're...
This part is what we're taking out.
11...
nine.
Okay.
I don't know if you heard that.
Like the whole piece cracked.
Oh my god.
Everything is cracking but the thing that I need to come
out.
Okay, we got 11.
Successfully extracted 11.
I should be a surgeon.
You would put your lives in my hands, right?
Look how well I'm doing.
I only broke one bone.
Let's get rid of some of these.
I would not.
Why not?
Be honest with me.
Why wouldn't you...
Why?
Um, um, why?
Why are you not trusting your life in Mito's hands?
Huh?
I'm gonna take this to your throat.
This is your throat!
I'm cutting through.
You don't need that.
You're done talking.
No, I needed that.
Think about when Minto is cute, which is always.
Which one was nine and which one was 11?
Oh well, maybe it doesn't matter.
Oh, I can tell.
11 is long.
No, 9 is long.
11's a little baby short.
How does this work?
Why are they sticking up in there?
So you take it and you go .
I'm afraid this won't fit.
I'm afraid it won't fit.
And then...
Sorry, I might have to do this one up.
Like, okay, so...
The open part...
is facing the back.
It's facing...
The back.
Okay.
That...
Nice?
Oh, it does fit.
It does fit.
Oh!
Would you look at that?
It fit in so easily.
And then 11 goes in as well.
Gloves.
Gloves, gloves, gloves.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, 11 is a little more tricky.
Probably because he's short but stout.
There we go.
Okay.
We got it.
Why do I... Why, though?
Why is this piece longer?
I can't tell why.
Hmm.
But we got it.
Our little AC unit.
So cute.
So, so cute.
Oh.
Okay.
E25.
There's more to this?
Why is this piece so intricate?
E25.
What was E?
E.
This is B.
This is I.
This is A.
Oh my gosh, this whole piece just came out in my hands.
This is F.
U.
G.
C.
D.
I got it.
How many of you guys have put one of these together before?
Two.
Thank you.
Thanks, kid party.
I admire your out-of-the-box thinking.
Housing prices are higher than ever, and here you are
building your own house size.
Wait, own size house to live.
No, no, it's for the gnomes.
What are you talking about?
It's not for me.
But I am trying to help out a poor gnome in a housing
crisis, yes.
E25.
Oh my gosh, there's so much on here.
Where would 25 even be?
If I were an E25, I'd be right here.
I found it.
I want to build this one.
and the forest one I saw.
Are you sure it's not just for the snake figure?
I'll be honest.
I didn't even consider that.
And now it's 100% for snake.
I didn't even consider this being for snake.
Oh, do you guys want to see him?
Wait, where does he?
He might be elsewhere.
He might be out on a mission right now.
He might be on, well, it's not, I was going to say he might
be on a philanthropy mission, but it's naked snake.
Where is he?
Snake?
Yeah, he's in his egg.
Hold on.
I think he's in my purse.
So that he can never leave.
Okay, how does this go?
It goes like this.
Oh, it fits in right there.
Oh, see?
I don't know if you guys can see it.
See, like, that outline, the little boxy outline in the top
left corner?
That's where this goes into.
Wait, do I have to glue it?
Oh, I do.
I have to glue it.
Okay.
I glue it.
I glue.
I glue?
Like, why, though?
Konami needs to announce the release date.
He won't be released until we get the game.
Okay.
Nice.
Please stand up straight!
Okay, whatever.
This goes in here.
And then I think we put E51.
Okay, just like that.
This is so intricate.
Why am I building the inside of this AC unit?
Nobody will see it!
Really?
I'm literally about to put the back on.
I think.
E51.
This is A.
For your satisfaction.
It has to be a functioning unit.
Or whatever.
What is the point?
Okay, 51 is right here.
Oh, gosh.
I got it.
Oh, okay.
Nice desk.
Matt, thank you.
And we still have our sign right here.
I'm gonna shave down these burrs.
Get them burrs.
This model was fun to build.
Good luck, Minto.
Thank you.
Everybody don't finish it.
That's okay.
I will, uh...
Oh, I put it like this!
Oh, that's fine!
Okay, I put it like halfway finished, or halfway open.
That makes even...
Okay.
Um...
Just slip that in there, I guess.
I wish I could use this side instead.
It's cleaner than this side.
See, this side has, like, a little hole in it.
Hmm.
Oh, well.
Okay.
Oh, I think
I got it.
Oh, there we go.
Hear that snap.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm like a chiropractor.
Yippee!
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I don't understand.
That was all step four.
Now we have a sign and an air con.
Okay.
Next is step five!
You guys, step five looks really exciting.
It's a lot of gluing, but we're getting into the trees.
I speak for the trees.
So we need F and C.
I know which one C is.
Which one is F?
Oh, I found F.
Okay, I need F 12.
Alex!
Thanks for the 10.
Thank you.
Thanks for the dono.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
F12, I think.
I need this.
Look, look, look.
We're getting into some colors, everybody.
F12.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Easy now.
Easy.
Easy, peasy.
Breezy.
Beautiful.
Cover girl.
Come on, come on, come on!
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
This part, this part's out, this part's out.
This part's out.
This part's out, this part out.
Ah!
Okay, we did it, we did it.
Okay, yeah, we did it.
Yay!
And this part goes with F.
And C.
Oh my gosh.
I just noticed C-19 and C-20 and C-21.
Look at all those tiny little...
All the individual.
All the...
I think they go on this.
See, you can kind of see an outline of a...
I think we'll be pasting them on that.
Gluing them there.
C-32.
This one.
okay this one this this is much thinner so it makes me even
more nervous okay okay okay nice nice just push down nice
and easy nice and easy easy gaming we're gaming we're gaming
hey oh my gosh i can't wait because this is going to add so
much like depth you know it's gonna add so much depth to our
little landscape all right so c32 hey excuse it your time is
over goes like this and then f12 goes like this and then
they wow they line up They line up!
That's so exciting.
This is so exciting.
This is the most excitement I might have had in a long time.
It's not perfect.
There we go.
That's more perfect.
Do I glue it?
I think I glue it.
I think I glue them together.
when gnome reveal my gnomes are very private gnomes so sorry
you may never ever see one but if I'm late for stream
usually it's because they've like messed up my setup you
know I'm trying to appease them so that I can be a better
content creator and less late for stream you know they're
just they're sassy little guys they're just so you're crying
you're like Minto's late it's not my fault blame the gnomes
blame the gnomes oh gosh oh gosh
I think this is even this looks even this looks okay now
sensei they are innocent you don't even know them the gnomes
hate us Yeah, they hit everybody, though.
That's why I'm hoping with this, they'll love it.
They'll be like our little beautiful Sakura Dream House.
I'm getting the glue out of the corners right now.
Nice.
The gnomes get a pass, but I don't!
What?
Why did the gnomes get a pass?
But, you know, before you even knew it, of the gnomes, you
were just like, meh, meh, but why the gnomes get a pass, but
meh, meh doesn't get a pass.
Messed up.
Alright, now we need C24.
And C22.
Oh, this one's a little complicated.
Okay.
C24, this.
Get the corners.
C24.
So now we're like kind of offsetting it when we glue it.
There we go.
C.
That looks good.
C24 and C22.
This one.
Nomes are cool.
They're just little guys.
I'm just, I'm little ghost.
I'm
a little ghost I'm just doing my best For you, to serve you
And to entertain you And to, you know, haunt you No Thank
you for the vibes Gifted, thank you Thank you
I think I could use a pass too That's all.
That's all.
Need to be fair with Nyanyan Maid level.
I will never be her.
Why not a second one for a little ghost?
Oh my god.
Oh.
You guys.
Oh my god.
Ah!
You guys, I just broke my chair.
Oh my god.
Oh, I just broke my chair.
And I don't know how.
Wait.
Um...
Wait, like...
I just broke my chair.
This is my chair!
Oh god, it's really dusty.
I just broke my chair!
I wasn't even touching it!
The gnomes did it.
The gnomes!
Oh my god.
Chair bud, thank you.
Oh.
What do I do?
I'll be your chair instead.
You!
Chair funds, stop!
But thank you.
Thank you for the chair funds.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, um, um.
Anyway, let's just continue onwards.
Okay, so we're taking C24.
Shoot, which one was 24?
Is it this one?
No.
Maybe this one?
This looks correct.
I think Like that And then C22 Goes Under How does this
work?
Huh?
But cradle fight Stop!
Terrible fight!
Stop!
Stop, stop, stop!
Snake dumpy fun!
I can't believe I just broke my chair!
Oh my gosh, I can't put my feet down.
Oh gosh.
Hold on.
Can you guys hear that?
I tried to...
I tried to fix it.
How did she break her chair?
I don't even know!
Okay.
No!
I can't fix it.
Oh!
Oh, it might have been a gnome attack.
Oh, man.
Oh, it's just a footrest.
But now the part...
Where the footrest went is a dangling metal thing.
And if I put my legs down, I kick it!
F.
Cherkun.
I'm saluting.
I'm saluting chair oh man um anyway okay I have to figure
out which one is C24 and which one is C22 because I can't
tell this is wait they both look the oh they're the are they
the same no uh oh they both They both look really similar.
Oh gosh.
I think this one is...
This one is C24.
This one's C24 and goes like this.
So I'm gonna glue it.
Check underneath me if there's any bolts.
Shook loose.
I'm looking!
Oh my god, I almost just pulled off my entire interface.
I don't see anything.
I don't know what happened.
I seriously don't know what happened.
Uh-oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You guys, I think my chair's coming undone.
I can't turn it.
Uh-oh.
You guys, I might have to end.
Oh.
If I turn my chair, it makes this horrible grading.
Uh-oh.
I can't turn my... Uh-oh.
You guys I think I lost my chair tonight
No way My chair My chair I'm gonna glue this real quick How
does it go?
Let's see Like No, it can't go like so
Maybe this is it No I'm confused Confused.
Oh my gosh, I can't turn my chair back and forth.
It's actually...
What's wrong with it?
What happened?
Chair could...
What happened to my chair?
Oh, it's like this, I think.
Okay.
I feel like I'm doing like a weird puzzle.
Like so?
No, that's too far off, I think.
I can't tell.
This area is really confusing.
This part is really confusing.
Okay, it's like this.
That's why it was so confusing.
But also, it doesn't line up.
The petals don't line up.
Do they line up here?
No.
Ha!
First my chair, now my brain!
Turn it into a chair fixing something.
stream why
chair oh I fix it I found okay okay I got it I got it I got
it I got it not my chair I didn't fix my chair I fixed this
okay hold on let's just glue it on while I have it let's
glue it on while I have it
so oh wait oh move it down a little there we go Like so.
Like so.
There we go.
I think that's good.
Super glue the chair, super glue everything!
How big the forehead.
What are you talking about?
My forehead's just a little big, okay?
Wires for the lights I got were too short and couldn't reach
all the lights.
No way.
No way, really.
Hopefully that doesn't happen with me.
oh there's like a lot of glue on the other side because i'm
an idiot but that's okay it's just for dimension right oh
wait some of these are off oh wait push push push push push
push no it's not already it's not already dried it can't be
oh i think it's already dried no way no it's a little
it's okay it's it's It's nature!
Nature is never perfect!
Nature is never perfect.
Now this one goes on...
How so?
Like this?
How does this go here?
Like this.
Oh, that's so cool!
That's so neat.
I got a little bit on the tip.
That's okay.
I'm just gonna glue the corner then.
I'm too scared of doing the rest.
Like so.
Okay.
Like.
Like so.
I think it'll stay.
I think.
I think it'll still stay.
I think it will still...
Oh shoot.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, there.
Yeah, perfect.
Perfection, perfection.
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah!
Wow!
We're so good.
Oh, it's so beautiful.
Oh, my gosh.
I like this side better.
This side looks good.
The side looks good.
Doesn't it?
Oh, there we go.
Nature is never perfect.
The rules of nature.
Thanks for the super chat.
Guys, I feel so discouraged with my chair.
I feel...
What happened?
Whatever.
Maybe it's just something weird and I...
I just don't know what happened.
I don't know what happened.
When I turn... Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna take off my headphones real quick.
Oh gosh.
I'm wondering if something, like, got stuck?
Oh, oh!
I'm an idiot.
I couldn't turn my chair because the metal bar that I told
you that started hanging down below was just... was stuck on
the ground.
I could turn it still.
Oh, okay.
It's just the...
It's just the little...
It's just...
It's just that.
It's just this thing.
I was like, oh my gosh, why can't I turn my chair all this
edit?
What's going on?
C.
31.
We need C 31.
Oh my gosh, this is also going on the same branch.
This one right here.
C 31.
Okay, wow, this is really full tree, isn't it?
C.
This part is like hanging on by a literal thread.
I'm like, come on, I'll need you later.
Just hold on for a bit.
That's C1.
I need C31 and I glue it to the top of, Our little branch.
Right here.
This part.
Hold.
I'm kind of confused.
I'm confused always, but, you know.
Glue has shown.
It's kind of tricky, though.
Like, here?
I guess.
Like that?
I think I don't know am I gluing it on the branch or on the
back of the I can't tell huh God couldn't thanks for the
gift oh I guess it doesn't have to be perfect nature nature
is not perfect do you guys want to say something I can do
with my hands I can wiggle my hands in a cool way don't look
at that part okay ready that's not the weak look watch watch
watch ready ready ready whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Whoa!
Whoa!
Isn't that pretty cool?
Kotkin, thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Easily distracted, Oshi.
Pretty good, but can you go the other way?
Wait.
So it's just this.
And this.
So if I go...
By golly, I'm doing it!
But...
Oh, it's like patting your tummy and rubbing your head.
Wait.
Doing
it!
This way is way easier.
By George!
It looks so bad!
It looks so ugly.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Anyway.
This part's confusing.
Glue as shown.
What is shown what?
I think it goes like this.
I think it goes up here.
I think.
I think so.
Or reverse.
Reverse, reverse.
No.
I think that's too high up.
I think I'm confused You should start a Discord Um There's a
fan Discord But I have no plans to start my own Um I'm sure
if you were curious about the fan Discord You could find it
somewhere Someone will give you the link probably I do not
have it I'm not in it They won't let me be in it You know
what I don't want to be in it either You know what if I make
my own Discord with blackjack and hookers.
You know what?
Forget the discord.
I'm just gonna...
You know what?
I'm just gonna get the blackjack.
Hold on, I'm cutting some pieces.
Okay.
I can't tell if it's up or down.
Hmm.
We're all around.
I guess it kind of looks the same.
Regardless of what I do.
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
Hold on, I'm cutting.
I'm nipping.
I'm nipping, I'm nipping.
It's the second time you said that reference today.
I just like that reference.
Bender's a funny guy.
It's been a long time since I watched Futurama.
And they're new episodes.
A Futurama?
Are there any good?
The newer episodes?
I say that all the time.
I think it's like one of the quote, like, besides, like, the
Take My Money quote, I feel like everybody's always quoting
Blackjack and Hookers.
You should start a Wisp colony on an oil rig in the Pacific.
Now that's an idea.
We can call it...
W-S-F.
Wisp, Sands, Phantoms.
They're okay?
I think you need Disney Plus.
I don't have Disney Plus.
W-S-F.
It's on Hulu.
I watched, what was that other show that the creators did?
It was on Netflix, I think.
No discord, so win next break stuff cover.
I don't know.
Oh, disenchanted.
Yeah, disenchanted.
It was okay.
I don't know if there's a new season.
If there is, I never watch it.
Yeah, the fantasy one.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
I think I need more glue on this.
I need more glue and more.
glue okay
okay dokey would it wasps and phantoms mean you aren't
allowed in either other phantoms probably wisps are special
and me she broke her chair oh yeah mint already broke stuff
give me something to break about my heckin chair help you
know i bought a new chair
trying to get the glue out from that that looks good i think
so far we oh my gosh you guys we're going to the next page
no way no way no way page five
page five yeah you're special all right what do you mean by
that i don't trust you What do you mean by that?
I have to fix my gloves.
My gloves, my gloves, my gloves.
Um, F9.
F, F, F, F.
F9.
Wait, where'd this other F piece go?
Uh oh.
Wait, we lost the biggest F.
Wait, wait, I lost this piece!
Uh-oh.
Wait!
Where did it go?
It's not what we need, but where is it?
It's just gone!
It's not with the rest of the Fs.
Uh-oh.
Huh?
It's literally not in the pile that I have.
But it's so huge!
You know what?
I'll save it.
That's a later Minto problem.
F9 is...
No, that's F6.
I was reading, I read the 6 upside down as a 9.
Hold on, let's read it properly.
F9.
Okay.
Ooh, this one's tricky.
We got this.
Okay.
Small, small, small, small.
Small, small, small, small, small.
It's the thing that reminds me of Shojo Ray.
Come on, there we go.
Nice.
I heard a snap.
I'm the chiropractor.
Let me adjust your bow.
YAY!
F9, C17, and C23.
Where does this other FBs go?
Craziness.
It's a mystery.
C17?
17.
It's like the same one, just...
Flatter.
There we go.
17.
And 23.
Nice suit.
Ah!
Oh, trying to keep this one held on.
We try to keep it held on.
The goblin took it.
God, no.
They're gnomes.
Get it right.
There's not goblins.
Only gnomes.
Am I gluing this?
Or...
Okay, this part's, this is a little confusing.
F9 was this one.
Which we have this side, this white side out.
Imp.
No!
Nomes!
You're gonna make them more angry at me.
Because you're mislabeling them.
They're gonna be more angry at me.
Oh, I'm gluing it!
Why didn't they just paint both sides instead of...
making me have more work for myself is my question why why
didn't they just paint both sides
hmm it's me I showed your way got any other ghastly songs in
the works I'll slowly pay my home fees to the gnome oh also
I'll slowly pay my home fees to the gnome owners associate
that's good that's good so you don't mistake the directions
oh why do you have to be so sensible
that seems to be oh I pressed down and so much glue came
oozing out I think I'm putting too much glue on this thing
you guys I think I'm overdoing it on the glue you legally
cannot own a gnome in what country tell me where name the
law the section everything and then I'll tell you I'm not
from there
get ghosted no mania
fake fake gotta sand this bottom part the law didn't stop
Willy Wonka he's convinced he saved those guys isn't it
actually wasn't okay so the johnny dep one was more accurate
than the gene wilder one right i don't i don't think in the
gene wilder one they touch on how he got the gnomes i mean
the umpalumpas but in johnny dep one he like goes to the
forest and then steals them i don't actually how does he
acquire them fan discord secured thanks minto i got you
Lore-wise, yeah.
Gene Wilder was just happier.
Johnny Depp is more in character.
Maybe that's why nobody likes it, because this character
sucks.
I thought I had broken it.
See, this piece...
Like, stops at the end, but this piece continues.
But it's obviously because it's supposed to go stuck into
the ground.
Lured them with B.
No way, that's what he did, actually.
The original author of the book actually hated the Gene
Wilder version because of all the deviations.
Well, it also sounds like it sucked.
You guys, I think I'm going to have to glue this one.
Send me your energy.
It's illegal in the country of your maid cafe.
Chuck mate.
No, no, no.
Send me your energy.
And then I'll put him back on.
Because I'm shy.
I'm gonna do it.
But don't look.
Okay.
Don't look at my nails.
Because they look really bad.
I'm scared.
No, I can't do this.
I'm sorry.
I took your energy.
And I ate it.
Thank you.
If you saw it, no you didn't.
It's starting to get shaky.
I wonder if I'm hungry.
I had some pizza, but I didn't like it.
They, like, put too much sauce.
And I'm not really a saucy gal.
Wait, but I'm saucy mint.
Uh-oh.
Hmm.
Will you trust my energy?
Maybe.
I don't know.
Why shouldn't I trust you?
Well, if it isn't saw cement.
I did it.
Super chat.
You're coming to anime north.
Um, I don't think so.
I don't know what anime North is.
Next year?
I can only go to cons if I get invited, you guys.
And if I'm not invited, then, you know, I can't go.
So if you want me to go to a convention, you know, you could
try asking them.
Be like, hey, I would really appreciate if you got the Mint
Phantom.
Oh, she's my favorite.
You know?
Truck con.
Yeah, but that was different.
That was, the truck people invited me, not the convention.
So, scandalous.
Stop.
Look.
Stop it.
Look, I'm back to being ghostly.
Gasly, in fact.
If I didn't wear these, you wouldn't see nothing, in fact.
Truly.
Yay, we have a traffic thing.
Now I need...
It says glue along the reference lines.
Got it.
I need C11.
Which is this guy, this little cross right here.
Oh.
Tiny hands.
Tiny hands to give you tiny beat down.
Smackdown.
F8.
Back to F.
There we go.
Oh, according to plan.
You want to get beat up?
Why am I acting like I'm surprised with that?
You cry before stream, but I know you like it.
Minto hates us.
I wish he'd hate me more.
You know?
I know you like it.
What else do we need?
F8, C11, C16.
Oh, C.
16.
C-16?
Do
we need C-17 also?
Just 16?
Oh, this is all C-16!
Both of these are C-16.
Make us feel alive, mental.
16.
There we go!
Wow, this one's a lot.
C14, this one, and C15, okay.
This one.
You've been invited to HandCon!
All you need to do is provide your fingerprint information.
Registered.
Okay, 16.
15.
Okay, I got it.
And we're doing it on this side, I believe.
Yeah.
I believe.
So this goes...
Wait, do we glue?
We glue this first, I think.
And then we glue it together, and then we put it here, and
then we put these on here, and then...
And then we put, even though they look a little goofy, they
look a little cheap, that's okay.
And then we put this somewhere.
Says there's reference signs, but there's really not.
You just put it, you just put it down.
Wait, does this have writing on it?
It's like almost hiragana, almost.
Where'd the other one go that I popped out?
Uh-oh.
A treasure mint running over me with her iPod.
I ran over you!
Oh wait, I do remember that.
I thought you meant like, unintentionally.
Guys, man overboard.
I lost a piece.
Man overboard.
Is that on my fingers?
No.
Uh-oh.
My tummy is rumbling.
Speaking of cons, can we give gifts at Otakathon?
Um, maybe.
I might have to, I'll be honest, I might have to start,
like, um, so, I'm running out of space.
You guys, I can't even show you the box of stuff that I have
from Off-Kai.
I don't know it's just in the box I don't know where to put
it I don't know where to put everything suffering from
success I guess so that's what you call that let's just glue
these ones down for now that I have hmm so I'm just kind of
like hmm I'm trying to like find a way to display stuff but
I'm also like where do where can I display it I might have
to buy more shelving and more maybe like display cabinet
things stuff like that no way I put too much glue on this
you I put just an appropriate amount of glue on this
Shelf building stream Download more shelf The maze cafe is
only You know I have to have room for tables and chairs For
patrons Otherwise I'll go out of business
Funds for renting a storefront Displainments gifts And merch
great perfect you solved it you solved you solved it you did
it you weird weird logarithm you solved the problem you did
it you did it the evil has been defeated I think I saw a
tweet about a hello project idol who rents out a separate
room just to store her fan letters and gifts no way new
house fund no I I like my mid cafe.
I like it.
I'm
gonna do it like that.
Do do do.
Beel, beel, beel.
Did someone say funding Mint's new house?
It's all the rage right now.
Trending on Twitter.
Funding, oh.
Funding this ghost's new haunting location.
Put me in Zach Baggins Museum.
I'd love to haunt that place.
Oh my gosh, this one is really tricky.
Okay.
Maybe like that.
And then we just let it sit.
Let it sit.
I think.
Here's a new house.
Oh, thank you.
Thanks for the super chat!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, wow, wow, wow.
Alright, let's glue these guys on.
How should I glue them on?
Okay, the little...
There's like a...
It's probably hard for you guys to see it, but there's a
little shine direction, and I want you to put it on the
left.
So it looks like the light is coming from...
Maybe... Oh my gosh.
Okay.
no gloves mode oh no gloves mode yeah
will you be at convention con this year you know what
convention con is like my go-to every year love that con
convention con so yeah you'll see me there oh I need the
glue
I'm shy
Oh, I think I put too much glue.
Oh my gosh.
No, my ex came off.
There we go.
Turn it around, town, baby.
Oh, I sure hope this dry is clear.
There's too much.
Too much glue!
Release the grippers?
No, I'm embarrassed.
I'm shy.
I'm shy ghost.
I can't.
It would be easier, but that's part of the challenge also.
It's with the gloves.
But also, I'm missing a thing.
There!
Oh my gosh, it looks so good!
From far away.
In the webcam.
It looks so great!
can't see the details you're just extreme boss I'm extreme
I'm extreme oh hi I
don't know where the other side of this went oh my gosh what
could have happened to it.
V for victory.
But no, we're missing a piece.
No victory here.
I hope I'm not like sitting on it.
I hope I didn't roll over top of it.
It's not on my dress.
I have no idea.
Where could it be?
Unless it's still...
Oh!
You guys, it was still it was still attached to the paper
that's what happened it was still attached
nice okay then i glue it all together
no not to the chair
okay i have to glue it like this and then i glue it in the
middle Okay, glue.
I think I might stop after this one because I'm getting
hungry.
I'm getting hungry is making me get a little shaky.
Oh my gosh, too much glue, too much glue, too much glue.
Too much glue!
But we're making progress.
I thought I would at least have like a base build or
something, but I...
I thought maybe that's where we would start.
I thought that they would be like, okay, we're gonna make
the build.
No, I guess you have to do the inside to build around it,
don't you?
I guess so.
No eating the glue.
I'm licking it from my glove.
I'm licking it.
I'm gonna have some mango.
I have some mango right here.
Hold on.
I'll show you guys.
Once again.
Just, I have to reach over.
I have some dried mango slices.
When do these expire?
It doesn't mold or anything, right?
There's only a couple pieces in here.
Yay!
Mango!
Yummy!
It only expired last month.
So it's fine.
Best buyer expired.
I don't know, it doesn't say.
Fresh food, but...
This is how slow I am to eat my boots sometimes, though.
Taste vibe.
Hmm.
Yeah, and I'm already a ghost.
Who cares?
Look at that.
That's not mold.
That's how it looks.
Would you like this?
Oh, it's glue?
No, now I have mango on my fingers.
Oh, I think I ingested a little bit of glue.
I hope it's non-toxic.
Look.
I hear old mango can be resuscitated by mixing it with
expired coffee jelly.
I'm still in a dream.
Glue eater.
Paste eater.
Oh, I agree.
That sounds better.
All right, let's glue this bad boy on.
Right about...
It just says glue it centrally.
Oh wait, hold on.
I want to sand down some of the edges first.
Glue centrally.
And then that will lead us to Step 7!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll show you guys my revolver that I made too.
Before.
And, uh...
awesome which side do i okay i think i just paste it just
like around you know what i'm just gonna put a little dab on
here not too much please don't come spitting out don't spit
out don't spit out i think it's drying on like the tip and
so it's spitting out okay just a dab will do you yeah there
we go a little more there oh that's i did too much why does
this happen to me there we go there we go oh god she has a
gun yeah i have a gun usually nobody allows me to have a gun
minto minto's never allowed to have a gun why oh let me to
have her gun let me have my gun please oh my gosh i cannot
Put this down.
There we go.
Okay.
Easy.
Yay!
Our traffic.
Danger zone.
Our danger zone stopper.
Oh, wait.
I think my sign's a little crooked.
There we go.
I fixed it.
Shh.
Don't touch it.
I was just trying to push it down so it would, you know...
Oh, God, this one's not dry either!
Uh-oh.
Guys, we're in trouble.
Okay, I gotta let it dry for 24 hours, probably.
Is the rate of dry it needs to do.
Probably.
Okay.
Yay!
That looks more straight.
That looks better.
We only had a few incidents today.
This breaking.
Losing that one piece.
But other than that, look at all this that we've completed.
Needed as well are one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight.
Eight items.
Vivian, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, and my chair.
Yes, I did break my chair as well.
Now we're on seven.
When do we?
Oh, number eight.
We start building the train.
Oh, wait.
That's F1.
Uh-oh.
I have to find that piece.
Where does such a massive piece disappear to?
Oh wait, no, that's F15.
But where did it go?
I'm at a loss.
Chocotaku!
Thank you for the five!
Thank you!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Also, I see people donating under the donations.
I think they're all backlogged.
Bye, Roblox, thank you.
She can't see us all.
Mintel cute.
I see you.
I saw you.
Space is ghost.
Thank you.
Oh, seven.
Chair Kun.
You know, thank you.
Chair fun, thank you.
Synapse, thank you.
Herman Minter fun.
Thank you.
Ashes, thank you.
Actual good pizza fun.
Let's go.
Ashes, thanks again.
Stop eating expired.
food you can't stop me you're not my mom try princess thank
you cool today was quite a day for me since I set all this
up I had to set up the streaming setup and I did VR and I
had to set all that up and I had to set up my model oh I
forgot to do some stuff today see you blubber welcome to
membership thank you
Really thanks!
Hope we have a chance to build Rex or some gunplay one
someday.
Well, actually, hold on.
I have a question for anyone who has done garage kits
before.
Uh-oh.
My chair's acting up again.
I got a garage kit at Wan Fest.
Of a Yuma Minamu.
And it was quite expensive, so I don't want to mess it up.
Like, look at that.
1,000 or 18...
10?
1, 8,000.
You did great today.
Thank you!
Thank you.
It's a resin or plastic.
I think it's plastic.
Dick.
You made me numb.
Look, it comes with some decals oh whoops they're my bad
they're very cute and then also she is it the braids the
braids the who do you need to paint it too yes do you paint
but Before you put it together or after you put it?
I think before, right?
Would be how you do it.
Look!
Oh my gosh, even the stand needs to be sanded down.
I just noticed.
Me.
I've never worked with a garage kit ever before in my
afterlife.
Also me.
Let's buy a really complicated...
Well, it's not...
I don't think it's so complicated.
I wish I could show you what she's...
Oh, hold on.
I can show you...
They have, like...
It's not colored in the picture, but...
She's very cute.
It could be more complicated.
Oh, sorry.
It could be more complicated, I think.
But...
That's the design.
It's the vocalized Yuma Minamu.
I know some people take commissions, but I don't know
anything specifically for I have thought about asking if I
should seeing if I should hire somebody or at least someone
who can mentor me through it.
I'm especially concerned about the decals because I don't
want to mess them up.
You only get one set, you know?
Hmm.
You need glue and putty.
Yeah.
Mentor.
Painting this would be tough.
You think so?
Well, it's like one step at a time, right?
And the colors are pretty basic.
I don't think there's like any gradients or anything like
that from what I can remember.
It's like all a bunch of solid colors.
So, hmm.
But I'm also concerned that it some of these pieces need to
be filed sanded and stuff hmm maybe i should have maybe i
should hire somebody i think i should hire someone some of
these pieces are like kind of It's really satisfying to
listen to, though.
Hold on.
Okay, I probably shouldn't rub these all together because I
don't want them to, like, break apart in there.
I don't want to break them apart in there.
Okay.
Yeah, I got it at Wand Fest.
See?
Wonder.
Wonder Festival.
Oh, you can't read it at all.
Gosh, it's webcam.
Oh, well.
have that I've been like wanting to wanting to put together
there's another wand fest at the end of this month there's a
wand fest I feel like there's more wand festes than than
like comic comic kits and stuff but um um what was I gonna
say um um Oh, uh, there, I, the, the, at the one fest,
though, um, that, I, actually, it was so crazy.
I was just wandering around and I was just, like, looking
around and stuff and, um, go into one area, um, where they
had, like, the more industry place it, industry booths and
stuff, and, um, the singer for Cruel Angels Thesis was just
performing.
I got to hear the singer, the original singer of Cruel
Angel's Thesis, what was it, Takahashi Yoko?
Sing Cruel Angel's Thesis.
Just randomly.
It's crazy.
That was so crazy.
I just walked up.
I was like, what's going on you?
Takahashi Yoko.
Okay, that was right.
I thought my weep card was about to be revoked there.
I thought I was about to have to get my weep card revoked
for getting the name incorrectly.
Yeah.
To answer some messages from earlier.
Oh, these are not made.
Oh, where other people confused.
Oh, yeah.
So a garage kit is basically like what Yoshi is saying.
Like they're, they're, they're, um, made by their fan made
so they're very um they can be very rough around the edges
um and uh they they are like not they're not painted usually
they're not assembled usually like you have to do everything
yourself so it's a little like a diy stuff you know indie
figures exactly that's what it is though yeah and um but you
can find them like so like uh there was one blue archive one
i almost got because i thought that they were pre-painted
but just needed to be assembled but it wasn't it was like a
rona and plana and swimsuits and they were they were so cute
i want that but yeah you know I never, that was the, that's
actually the first garage kit I've ever bought because I, I,
um, I don't do painting.
So I was just like, oh, I saw one of those.
Yeah, I saw two of them.
There was one that I was just like, cute until when you need
to assemble and paint.
I know.
And they make it look so good in the pictures.
Oh, I think I will hire somebody though.
Somewhere, somehow.
Wherever I can find somebody who does garage kit painting.
I don't know if I, like, you know, I could probably find...
I mean, not probably, but I could find somebody who does,
like, miniature paintings and things like that.
But I think it's a little different.
So...
A lot of prep required.
I built garage kits before.
Oh, yeah.
And I don't have an airbrush, which I feel would be...
Um...
Which I feel would be...
It will lower the quality I feel, you know?
It's a damn fine figure.
Why the hell does a vine look like that?
I know!
I would be like...
No!
Mine turned out so ugly and I got it!
And it was so expensive and I love this character so I
wanted to look good and...
But yeah.
You and Matara need to paint Warhammer minis.
oh yeah I know when I when we were recording the Warhammer
episode for the Patreon which comes out this coming Monday I
was like looking out there they're tiny they're teeny teeny
tiny but I've watched painting videos before like how you
like do the like why I say it's kind of different I feel
like to the to the garage kit I have is because like to do
the shadows and stuff you can like paint the black and then
paint over it and it kind of like does that layering effect
and stuff like that but um I recently finished the BHA's
final episode
with Shiroko it's so emoy
but yeah you can use inks for that too oh really they're
pretty different from garage kit painting yeah cole you
probably wait you make figures have you ever done one garage
kit painting you had to paint the figures you've made right
so oh aru steals the show in the anime well that's because
also i mean yeah she's she's so cute but uh they they um
focused on on them what was there the problem solvers 68 67
66 65 as a painter of tabletop minis it's rough but
sometimes it's rewarding yeah I can imagine with the minis
it's like so much patience but also probably with those you
would assemble them first right because I feel like the
parts are too many to paint before you assemble it.
They were like this big.
69.
Depends on the mini.
Ah.
Sometimes you paint before assembly.
So much patience.
Too much patience.
My tea has gone cold.
So sad.
No.
It's been a few hours.
Wait, how long have I been streaming for?
Three hours!
I'm tired.
Is it okay if I go to sleep?
Well, not sleep.
I have some stuff I need to work on that I didn't get to
work on today because I was too busy setting up for this
stream.
and setting up for the stream earlier.
I gotta respond.
I have a whole list of things of me being like, reply to
this email, reply to this email, reply to this email.
Oh!
I gotta send my address.
They're gonna ship me a sample of my product.
Yippee!
Next week is my...
You guys, next week is my anniversary.
Next week, I'm...
finally able to celebrate my first year anniversary.
I graduated or I graduated before I got to celebrate it.
And now I get to celebrate my first year anniversary.
Even though it's my four year anniversary.
First year.
I think because it's my first time celebrating.
Maybe I can say it's My first year anniversary.
I'll be honest.
I don't have so much plan because I don't have so much plan.
But.
Mint 1.0 debut watch along.
Oh my gosh.
That would be wild.
I feel like usually for like...
say you debuted and then you watch your one year your debut
at your one year anniversary I feel like I remember it you
know but this I didn't have a proper debut actually I had a
video that I put up and then I had like a stream where I
answered some questions but even in the stream I didn't like
do a PowerPoint or anything like that so um but yeah I will
have some announcements of stuff um but uh probably nothing
that i don't know if pre-orders will be up um for the things
pre-orders will probably be up or more towards august and
then i hope you'll be patient with me um for uh shipping
stuff as well um but uh yeah I have some stuff.
Emma said, thank you for this super time.
Thank you.
Oh.
In the May Cafe, straight up kissing it.
Wait, that's old.
That's old.
By it.
Well, let's just say my Sakura Densha.
Stop.
Shut up, Ducky.
Also, I saw that spank.
It says she's not looking at these.
So cute.
Now I do look at the donuts.
It was two hours ago.
You're right.
It was relevant at the time.
I still would have told you to shut up.
But yeah, I have some fun stuff to announce.
I feel like I'll have more things to announce, maybe more
towards my birthday.
But that's a while from now.
The gifted memberships lag it so much.
I know, right?
I wish there was a way to turn it off.
Well, not turn off, like, turn off the notice from clogging
it up.
so that it's not just notify after notify after notify
notify after notify you know but um October I think will be
my month it is my month because I'm a ghost anyway it's a
spooky month I started fostering a cat today any tips wait
is your first cat ever if you're fostering it are you
fostering to adopt are you fostering so that they get
adopted by someone else I don't think I could ever foster to
get adopted by someone else because I'd love the cat too
much yeah so if you guys just be a little patient with me
until like October which I know is quite far away what we
got August where it's we're mid we're or coming up on the
end of July already which is crazy but August September two
months and then October will be my month Yeah, I think.
I hope.
I hope so.
I'm praising.
Um.
Yeah, so that's stuff.
That's just some general stuff coming up in the work, in the
workshops.
Praising.
Yeah.
Of course, Minto.
Oh, I just dropped that.
That's gone forever.
No, what else am I supposed to fiddle with?
My scissors.
So, um, yeah.
Don't play with scissors.
Don't play with scissors, children.
Um, yeah.
I don't think...
Sorry, I was like, I don't think I have any other updates,
announcements, stuff, but, um...
I didn't realize that this I didn't mean for this to turn
into an announcement thing
Scissors ASMR Minto hands Aren't he a ghost I just got here
That's why I have the gloves on Otherwise I'm you know I'm
I'm you know Watch watch it'll go through it It goes through
my hands You
see?
You see?
New announcement.
Minto cute.
You say that again.
That wasn't a threat.
It was a promise.
Just go straight through my hand.
See?
through my head.
Threatening with flowery scissors.
Shut up.
It's been a while, Minto!
You know who I am, boop.
I do know, actually.
How is Sensei doing?
Covered in glue?
Sensei is all sealed up.
I hope there's no glue.
If so, I'm going to have to lick it off, probably.
No, I think I got all of it.
I think we're good.
sealed away forever
anyways guys I'm gonna head out you have a wonderful rest of
your night I think I probably will work more on this off
stream I don't know if I will stream the rest to be honest
but if I do intend on streaming it I'll get some more done
if I don't intend on streaming it I'll get as much as I can
done or I'll finish it and I'll take a picture for you guys
Obviously.
Um...
Oh!
Oh, my revolver!
Yeah, hold on.
Let me show you my revolver.
What?
So this is my revolver that I made.
And it came with these cute little people that I can shoot.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh wait, I don't know where the rubber bands are.
But, um...
You can...
This is so awesome!
Akiba Man Wars is getting freaky with this raid.
Yeah.
Look how beautiful.
It's the most beautiful weapon ever created.
I had to, like, put all these individuals together and then,
like, get it in there with the spinny wheel and everything.
You're pretty good.
six shots enough to kill anything that moves
i've got six shots
i'm so organized i'm so organized i'm so organized look at
this look at this
Feeling lucky?
Oh my gosh, are we going to play Russian roulette?
So you, like, take the rubber band and put it like this.
And like that.
I think?
No, you don't.
I just shot it backwards.
Hold on.
You take the rubber band and you put it like this.
I think?
Put it like that, like on the front to here.
You can see it.
Oh!
It went so fast, you couldn't even see it fly!
Real gun.
Yeah, so I keep this on my little shelf with all my other
Metal Gear stuff.
And then, oh, it's fun to shoot the people.
Hold on.
Don't take that out of context.
It's fun to shoot the wooden people.
Would you ever consider collecting airsoft?
Yes, actually.
I've looked into it.
I've gone to like airsoft stores in Japan, but I'm afraid of
bringing them back.
I haven't gone to an airsoft store in the United States yet.
Let's watch this.
Ready?
Aim!
Steady?
Friend?
Fish!
Fah!
Oh!
Ready?
Steady!
Friend!
Oh, wait!
Confuse your enemy, you must first confuse yourself.
Those engravings on your revolver?
No, they're not!
No, it's just...
It's not engravings!
It's not engraving!
They're pretty good.
Have to work now.
Can I have a bit of a hand wiggle for the road?
Here you go!
Sorry I saw this late, David!
No tactical advantage.
Okay, bye everybody!
Thank you for hanging out with me today.
That's so much fun.
Here's your dose of...
If you're eating something, if you're drinking something,
here you go.
Some moe magic that I can spread to you!
Choo!
Here's some moe moe magic.
Get out of the way, little person.
OYSIC NARE!
Moe!
Oh, sorry.
Cute!
Now your food is delicious and moe-tastic.
Who was that?
GOSU!
Thanks for the vibe gifted.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
Have a great day or night or whatever time it is for you.
And I will see you guys tomorrow playing Metal Gear Solid 2.
And...
Yeah!
Atsumito!
Atsumito, Atsumito, Atsumito, Atsumito.
Oh, actually, hold on, before we go.
Special occasion.
One sec.
There we go.
Whoa!
If there's something strange, please, please, please,
please.
Bram, bram, bram, bram, let me tell you something.
If there's something weird, sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Busting makes me feel good.
Berta, berta, berta, berta, berta, berta.
Busting, busting, busting.
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin oh
let me tell you something oh Yay!
Thanks for the five kisses!
Bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin makes me feel good.
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, feels good, feel good, feel
good, feel good.
Freaking man, baby.
Now we sleep in the old bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
Shadow Demon Lord, thank you for the gift!
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no beds.
Two, two, an invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin Bustin
Bustin Thank you for the five, give ten!
I feel good!
See you guys later!
Bye-bye!
Thank you!
Thank you, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!